[Music]
avatar being a virtual representation of
a human being and in this case it's a
biological representation of the female
reproductive tract so we call it Eva
Tarr so the system that we've invented
together with Draper laboratories is a
series of interconnecting cubes that
have individual tubes that now connect
each of the organs so we would have
actual samples from enough so we would
have like a mouse ovary cultured on one
of these strands well the fluid can
dynamically flow between all of these
individual different compartments just
like each of our organs do as if blood
was carrying factors between different
organs so this would be the ovary so
it's coming from here going into here
and then flowing it's a little miniature
ovary so you we actually have either the
individual follicles from the ovary and
a follicle in the ovary are the cells
that make the hormones like estrogen and
progesterone together with the O site or
we can actually have the entire ovary
there and that allows us to control the
hormones over a 28-day menstrual cycle
in a box so understanding how the uterus
responds to hormones is really important
there is no animal model for a lot of
the stuff that we study and so the human
is really the perfect model to study the
end the human endometrium the uterus and
the diseases that are associated with it
we were able to actually acquire primary
human tissue from women who were having
surgeries for different minstrel or
reproductive related problems this is
the first time we've been able to
model the entire reproductive hormone
profile and that profile of menstrual
cycle hormones now allows us to connect
those dynamic hormones to downstream
tissues like the fallopian tube uterus
cervix together with a liver and that
integration now will allow us to
understand better about the reproductive
tract itself which we don't have good
models for as well as reproductive
diseases so now this is going to allow
us to test drugs for individuals so
we'll be able to eventually make
individual organs from each person so
we'll be able to do personalized
medicine it's really going to open a
whole new world of reproductive health
testing
[Music]